okay ich habe die meldung bekommen dass
das buch da ist was im shop angekommen
und ich finds dahin natürlich kommt der
hammer auch mit aber ich will schon so
eben sonst immer die letzte die ins auto
steigt und jetzt sitze ich hier und
warte einfach auf haben sie allein das
ist schon ein highlight
[Musik]
hier erste verpackt und wenn kein wohnt
sind alle rollesbroich es ist da weil
erstes eigenes kochbuch ist jetzt
offiziell das war glaube ich noch nie so
aufgeregt ein video zu beginnen wir
heute einfach aus dem grund weil wir
sind jetzt viereinhalb jahre auf youtube
und ihr sagt mir seit jahren kiki kaum
so wann kommt jetzt ein buch jetzt mach
mal 1 und ich habe jetzt so ein respekt
davor war ich weiß wie viel arbeit das
ist und ich habe es halt immer so ein
bisschen hinausgezögert weil wir haben
ja auch viele andere projekte und nicht
will immer 100 prozent in eine sache
steckt und ich kann euch heute so wie
ich hier sozusagen das hier war das mit
abstand an strengste projekt etwa und
wenn du mich auf instagram verfolge dann
wisst ihr was wir sonst so alles machen
also wir ja wir stehen halt nie still
und ich wusste einfach wenn ich ein buch
mache dann werde ich erst mal ganz viel
fleiß schweiß herzblut und vielleicht
auch die ein oder andere träne
reinstecken ja es war wirklich voll die
turbulente zeit in den letzten wochen
und monaten war es halt so ich habe das
buch gelebt irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl gehabt nicht war wirklich von
morgens bis nachts beziehungsweise
wieder morgens war ich verteile weise
erst um vier uhr morgens im bett war ich
für das buch darf halt anfangs so ist
die ganze zeit super motiviert und
gerade am anfang war ich total
euphorisch einfach mal damit zu beginnen
ja ich zeige euch einfach mal ein paar
ausschnitte aus der zeit mein erstes
foto mein erstes rezept das aufwendigste
pas de deux dass es so lecker der
aufwand lohnt sich und guck mal wie es
hier aussieht hier ich habe auf der
arbeitsfläche ausprobiert wie das muster
sein könnt ich habe dafür einfach mein
akku liter genommen
super geklappt jetzt kommt der klassiker
die linsensuppe aber da gefällt mir das
gar nicht gucke ich mal dass ich ein
anderes brett finder
damit ich mich jeden tag daran erinnere
habe ich hier direkt wenn man von der
tür reinkommt an der wand meine ganzen
zettel stehen froh wenn ich das schon
mal ein paar von abreißen kann weil das
echt noch viel arbeit ist sie auf mich
zukommt
leute neuer kühlschrank am start weil
ich einfach kein platz mehr hatte und
ich habe noch platz alles rein zu tun
ich bin froh ich bin froh ich bin seit
okay ich bin seit acht stunden am kochen
und backen ungefähr acht dinge parallel
und damit schreibe ich halt immer die
ganz genau in grimma habe ich hier
hannover schicken das ist eine syrische
spezialität die habe ich von pianist
erstmal durch hansa kennengelernt und
das muss auf jeden fall mit ins buch
weil das so ein syrischer klassiker ist
aber ich bin einfach nur mit alle
knochen gerade weh ich also meine beine
unter der sohle es brennt ist print
richtig
komm schon ja meine belohnung gibt
nichts besseres
[Musik]
ok 13 stunden sind vergangen haben den
ganzen tag videos geschnitten und ich
habe den ganzen tag zwischendurch halt
immer das set fertiggemacht sachen
gekocht und gebacken so ist aus und ich
konnte so lecker essen zwischendurch
wir haben heute echt viele verschiedene
rassen und das wird mir richtig toll
sagt ist ja ich habe heute heute so oft
die sich auch geräumt und die smart ist
guckt mal wie das hier aus sieht echt
lecker ist auch noch welche richtung ist
meine achte maschine heute hier gefällt
mir die höhe nicht ich mag den morgen
noch mal neun mit anderen mengenangaben
ja so ein bisschen aber mein einziger
trost ist dass ich zwischendurch meisten
na ja ich glaube leute kommen leute
richtig so katastrophal gut aussieht ich
bin jetzt so einige leute jetzt sagen
hey komm ich helf dir das ist doch viel
zu viel arbeit für dich alleine hier
gott behälter hat könnt ihr aber mit dem
jungen das ist eine orientalische also
in deinem buch wird dass wir das ist
einfach dein buch wie so authentisch ich
muss auch sagen voll oft wenn wir
youtube videos drehen dann mache ich
auch immer das ziel dafür bin ich ja mal
zuständig nach wie vor oft vor zweifel
ich suche in der ganzen wohnung nach
irgendwelchen den artikeln oder was kann
es dann noch mitmachen und tolstoi es
jetzt gut und ist jetzt ist mir immer
was schönes zum thema ein
und glücklich superschicke socken mir
jetzt eigentlich noch 30 bis 39 morgens
ich bin ich so motiviert aufgestanden
und dass der unterschied ist ja ich will
jetzt auch jeden einzelnen bürger cup
deswegen habe ich hier immer meine waage
meinen laptop und dann rechne ich
nämlich auch die nährwerte für ein
röllchen das habe ich an meinem video
nicht ich bin nicht verzweifelt also bin
heute also heute waren es glaube ich 13
stunden bis jetzt und bis jetzt lief
alles am schnürchen in immer was
gefunden an deko also immer was
passendes gefunden und sofort auf anhieb
gefallen und jetzt beide bei der
leckersten torte elfer bin ich voll am
verzweifeln
ich weiß einfach nicht wie sie die kopie
und europa irgendwie fassen die grünen
töne nicht zusammen
ich glaube ich nehme an der unterlage
[Musik]
es ist ohne zweifel die date android
immer näher
sowieso eindruck ein ich hab ich mir die
letten einen selber gesetzlich könnte
auch sagen kommen später aber nein was
muss das muss rostock dapd sehr lecker
ist sehr sehr lecker seine fröhlichkeit
ist sondern machen trotzdem lieber essen
dann nicht und hallo da kommt was
wiederum eine herausforderung ist es
halt das alles im buch schritt für
schritt zu erklären dass man es halt so
verschieden wie den videos und das ist
eine herausforderung drastik ich hier
landschaft jetzt letzten schon ein
rezept abgetippt und das noch freund
gebe ich meine oma schritt für schritt
und kocht das vielleicht auch nach und
ob du das verstehst die mainzer top und
die ist keine große flächen oder das
sich so gut dass nicht so gut sagt
katharina dort aber diese thymian
mischung habe ich rein gemacht diesmal
also es ist nicht eins zu eins ist was
ich schon online hab ich habe es noch
mal so ein bisschen verfeinert
[Musik]
so das ist unser heutiges abendessen und
haben sie einfach die fotos ist das dein
beruf fotografen sein hobby das ist mein
hobby und das ist einfach und bücher für
ein kochbuch bücher hat ein kochbuch ein
verrücktes rennen kommt ja ich meine
genau wie thomas ja auch auf seinem
kochbuch kassen zur hobby beispiellose
menschen
wir haben hier mal diese ganzen ort
boxen steht dann haben wir ein kleines
set eigentlich liegen immer ganz viele
bretter und das mache ich immer fertig
dann kommt hamza macht einen test foto
und was ändern wenn es uns dann gefällt
dann macht haben wir ganz ganz viele
fotos
ich glaube aus hunderten fotos müssen
wir uns dann später wirklich so 12 fotos
und wegen 1 eigentlich aussuchen müsste
dann nehmen so jetzt geht angst
dekorieren also ich jetzt nicht mehr
geschafft war gestern noch bis 3 uhr
morgens in der kirche wenn er um 9 uhr
aufgewacht und es macht einfach weiter
und so sieht es natürlich noch mag ich
auch da müssen noch nüsse und bis 16
dran und ich finde dass es einfach immer
super festlich aussieht also dass hier
sind einfach so so hübsch aus
[Musik]
so heute ich muss eigentlich noch drei
gerichte kochen am vor die sonne
untergeht würde ich gern auch auf dem
balkon fotos machen und die fotos macht
natürlich kein geringerer als hansa und
ich versuche verschiedene fotos zwischen
den verschiedenen kategorien noch mit
einzubringen damit die auf ist hey das
ist kiki blätter nicht vergessen genau
jenes raus ist richtigkeit draußen 6
grad oder so
[Musik]
so und jetzt mal reallife weil ich
unbedingt diesen vorgang zeigen heute
und die blogging kämen gesucht habe 23
minuten an ist in der zwischenzeit
einfach schokolade schon zu hart
geworden zum verstreichen
egal ich nehme jetzt noch mal alles ab
und kann sie dann noch mal neu auflegen
man man man nur will ich euch gerne
mitnehmen wollte
[Musik]
heute ist donnerstag der vierte dritte
ich habe meine eigene deadline um vier
tage oder so überschritten
am sonntag ist abgabe um mir fehlen noch
genau also mir fehlen noch acht rezepte
für die ich jetzt noch zwei tage zeit
hat das schaffe ich auf jeden fall
und jetzt kommt der moment der momente
jetzt kommt im moment ich habe die ganze
darauf gewartet diese wand hier endlich
zu entfernen weil ich davon dass meister
abgehakt habe 15 pisten wegschmeißen
aber dann muss ich mir wieder auf den
boden
also ich habe hier meine rezepte haben
tag drauf geguckt nachts schlafen gehen
was muss ich noch machen was fehlt mir
noch plötzlich kam in neue ideen es
kamen neue rezepte mit auf die wand weil
ich mich einfach nicht entscheiden
konnte und jetzt werdet ihr einen punkt
wo ich genau weiß dass ich meine
deadline einhalten werde zumindest meine
zweite gesetzte deadline und ich diese
band nicht mehr brauche ein richtig
geiles gefühl werde
[Musik]
die verzweiflung ist eigentlich aber ich
glaube wir sind jetzt in den endspurt
lecker lecker lecker lecker lecker
lecker heute das jetzt sehr lecker und
mussten 40 heute fazit für heute ist
also ich hab hier geschafft doch schön
fotografiert muss man für popstars geben
hat mich aber es ist nicht belastet
leute aber wenn ich das video angucken
welt werde immer dankbar sein dass es
vorüber ist weil dieser prozess ansicht
der macht spaß und ich lief voll auf
aber dieser spielverderber dieser ganzen
geschichte ist einfach das aufräumen
einfach spielverderber
die folge war dass ich mir kurz das ist
nur 30 38 konzertstunden wieder 23 34
uhr das ist mein zweites buch mache
[Musik]
das schmeckt so lecker
manchmal sind die einfachsten dinge die
in der kasten
[Musik]
krismer
also es gab wie gesagt viele viele lange
nächte haben sie lag schon im bett oder
praktika kommst du derart meistens
braucht einfach der stelle möchte ich
einfach mal sagen es ist
selbstverständlich ich weiß aber hier
steckten 100 prozent haben so und kirche
drin das heißt alle rezepte wurden von
mir selbst entwickelt um mir selbst
gebacken und gekocht von hamza
fotografiert werde es also nicht
irgendwie eine agentur gegeben oder wir
haben uns keiner arbeit abnehmen lassen
natürlich so gewisse dinge wie die
grafik danke wurde an der stelle für die
tolle grafik da haben wir uns
zusammengesetzt wie wir die grafik
machen sollen was ist für euch am besten
wie könnt ihr die rezepte zu hause am
einfachsten nach machen ohne dass jetzt
ein video von mir habt da hatte ich halt
immer meinen laptop bei mir denn nicht
und habe dann auch immer wieder wenn mit
tipps zwischendurch eingefallen sind
habe ich die notiert habe auch dinge zum
beispiel wie zum eine bastelei die habe
ich extra tief gefroren dann noch mal an
einem anderen tag geschaut wie verhält
sich das wann muss ich das jetzt hier
raus holen damit sie genau so knusprig
ist weil wie viel grad muss sie dann
tiefgefroren in dem backofen und das
sind so wertvolle tipps das ist
natürlich auch so ein bisschen der
unterschied zu meinen youtube videos bei
youtube videos erkläre ich euch alles
schritt für schritt damit damit die key
garantiert damit das gelingt aber hier
sind nochmal so ultra wertvolle tipps
mit drin die ich halt extra für euch
selbst herausgefunden habe und daher
steckt einfach unglaublich viel arbeit
mit drin kurz zu den fakten in diesem
buch mit hardcover und einem schönen
glanz hier vorne orientiert kitchen sind
enthalten 112 seiten mit 40 rezepte 29
herzhaften und elf süßen rezepten
kontakte durch meine schwiegermama und
ich meine familie ich habe so viele
authentische rezepte kennen gelernt und
halten nach eigenem belieben noch
verfeinert und tipps und tricks dazu
geschrieben und es sind super wertvolle
rezepte wie ich finde
und sie schmecken eigentlich so jedem
gaumen sag ich mal sitzt nicht super
super super exotisches dabei wo man in
bordeaux das passt einfach nicht sondern
hier ist alles stimme ich wissen auch
rezepte die könnt ihr zum mittagessen
kochen bisher als oder dinge zum
abendessen und sie ist eigentlich für
jeden was dabei
kikis oriente kitchen ist einfach ein
kochbuch mit orientalischen rezepten wie
es der name schon verrät und ich habe
mir gedacht ich mache so eine
dicke reise durch den nahen osten wobei
ich auch ein indisches rezepte drin habe
oder auch wollte ich nicht verzichten
und es ist wirklich so weit ihr das buch
eröffnet dann liest sich das so ein
bisschen wie eine geschichte also lasst
euch auf jeden fall auch die texte durch
dich dazu geschrieben habe fangt einfach
mal an den kochlöffel zu schwingen wenn
ich glaube wenn man auch die bilder
sieht bekommt man direkt lust sagt
nachzukochen insgesamt sind hier 40
rezepte drin und zwar 40 vollwertige
rezepte was bedeutet dass warum sage ich
dieses wort machte dazu es gibt halt
auch bücher das ist total legitim ganz
also jeder wie er mag ich wollte dass in
diesem buch nicht haben
da werden rezepte wie zum beispiel eine
dattel die man dann befüllt oder ein
getränk wo man zwei zutaten zusammen mit
oder 3 wird dann als rezept deklariert
und für mich ist es eher so ein
serviervorschlag und kein richtiges
rezept hier sind eben 40 super super
vollwertig anspruchsvolle rezepte drin
die aber auch wiederum jeder machen kann
weil ich habe in diesem buch die
schritte so beschrieben dass ihr
wirklich so schritt für schritt
durchliest und einfach mit kommt und
nicht denkt auch was ist jetzt hier oder
damit gemeint ihr soll zu hause das
gefühl haben beim lesen als wird ihr
meine stimme hören und die kicker aus
dem videos kennt erklärt euch das bei
euch in der küche und ich habe das auch
schon testweise freundin der familie
gegeben und ihr müsst durchgelesen und
meinen titel hast du so toll beschrieben
und jetzt kommen noch ein paar andere
dinge die wo ich einfach gedanken
gemacht habe und bei denen ich finde
dass sie echt einmalig sind ich habe zum
beispiel jede zutat natürlich
chronologisch sortiert das ist nichts
neues aber was ich gemacht habe ich habe
jede zutat in der beschreibung wenn sie
vor kommt noch mal fett markiert das
hilft euch beim kochen den farben nicht
zu verlieren und zu schauen wo wann
kommt denn die und die zutat dran damit
ich bescheid weiß dass sich das
vorstellt muss et cetera
aber auch das erkläre ich euch in aller
ruhe in dem buch dann kommt eine ganz
wichtige rubrik nice to know leistung
ist für mich so wird unter das
wichtigste weil da gibt's noch mal super
super interessante tipps und tricks oder
in ihm mal eine zutat nicht habt wo
gehen könnt ihr die eintauschen wie
könnt ihr das einfrieren wie lange hält
sich dass wieder richtige portion wenn
ihr mal besuch bekommt etc
das steht alles immer unter dem rezept
in der rubrik leisten
ich versuche halt irgendwie so viele
interessante und wichtige informationen
wie möglich raus zu finden
das ist der unterschied auch zehn
youtube-videos bei einem youtube-video
ich mach das rezept ich zeige es euch
schritt für schritt damit jeder versteht
ich gebe euch tipps definitiv aber ja im
buch finde ich dann muss schon ein
bisschen das ist schon ein bisschen
special seien und daher mache ich jetzt
folgendes ich hab nämlich vor einer
woche ungefähr meine castella zubereitet
und gebacken ich habe aber die hälfte
davon extra tief gefroren im tiefkühler
um jetzt herauszufinden wie ihr sie zu
hause am allerbesten dann im backofen
auf soll der backofen schon vorgeheizt
sein ist es besser wenn ihr den während
des verhaltens werde die post schon rein
gibt wie viele minuten brauchen sie
damit so schön knackig sind das sind
alles so infos die kosten mich extrem
viel zeit aber die sind gold wert in
eurer vorbereitung fürs essen und daher
mache ich mit dem ion ich finde also ich
persönlich würde ich mein kochbuch
kaufen ich würde feiern wenn solche
informationen da drin stehen und diese
aber auch zuverlässig sind
die sind jetzt noch tiefgefroren und ich
mache jetzt den test
[Musik]
perfekt dann habe ich mir auch überlegt
wir machen nährwerte mit rein die
nährwerte pro portion für alle
kalorienzähler für alle die einfach
wissen wie viel ein was ist da drin wie
viel fett und da haben wir uns auch die
mühe gemacht und gedacht wir schreiben
das jetzt für jedes rezept aufwächst du
das jetzt hier unterschiedlich liegt das
weil ich von jedem rezept proportion die
die exakte nährwertangaben zu rechnen
möchte ich glaube dass viele draußen
kohlenhydrate eiweiß achten das brachte
mich kalorien aussagen finden angaben
über nation was wir uns sogar überlegt
haben wenn das wieder online geht dann
wissen ob es gemacht haben oder nicht
aber erlebt habe recht unseren tag den
kopf darüber ob wir noch den preis pro
portion daneben gehört eigentlich jedes
mal wenn ich das so sagen okay ich weiß
auch wie viel das kostet das gericht ja
man kann also sehr schafft genau es gibt
für jede chance mit den
durchschnittlichen preise 1 marken und
eigenmarken also designprodukte aber man
könnte das recht machen neben dem
schwierigkeitsgrad damit einfach
einschätzen können ist es jetzt für
anfänger geeignet oder er so für hobby
profi köche haben wir natürlich auch die
portionen angegeben die minutenzahl wie
viel zeit ihr euch einplanen ist und
jetzt kommt's ich habe das so noch nie
vorher gesehen aber ich fand's einfach
cool wir haben den durchschnittlichen
preis pro portion errechnet wieso war
mir das wichtig die habe ich das gefühl
das ist eine wichtige info natürlich
gibt es leute die achten gar nicht
darauf was die für nahrung ausgeben aber
es gibt auch leute die müssen dann halt
schauen wie viel sie für ihren einkauf
ausgeben und wenn ihr dann vielleicht
mal die familie einladen oder einfach
mal ein überblick kamen möchten okay ich
koch jetzt das und das und das rezept
aus dem buch nach was kostet mich das
eigentlich proportionen dann die dass
hier auch nochmal errechnet das sind
durchschnittliche werte wir sind also
nicht von den billigsten brand von den
günstigsten preisen gegangen ich von den
höchsten sollen wirklich von den
durchschnittlichen mittelwerten und ich
persönlich finde es einfach cool
aussehen wo da noch mit dran steht und
ich habe mir noch überlegt ich schreibe
euch immer noch drunter in lautschrift
wie man das jeweilige rezept ausspricht
das habe ich auch ein coole ideen könnt
ihr einfach mal ganz laut nach sprechen
und dann wird es für angeht nicht
türkisch und arabisch sind
es ist eine ganz interessante sache
viele haben mich auch gefragt wenn es
eigentlich rezepte die schon auf dem
kanal gibt und wird es die dann auch
noch nach unten
nach geben also es ist so hier sind ein
paar rezepte drin war ich hab natürlich
ist in den letzten viereinhalb jahren
auch schon unglaublich viele
orientalische rezepte gemacht auch als
der traditionelle und selbst tolle
rezepte aber ich hab sie hier teilweise
noch einmal aufgegriffen aber nicht
hauptsächlich also sie sind noch viele
neue rezepte drin
zum beispiel ist hier drin taschen
verlag will dabei aber ganz viel
nachgefragt oder albanische trilogie
dann habe ich noch knoblauch nahen also
hier sind wirklich richtig coole neue
rezepte auch drin und ich glaube die
geht es auch erstmal nicht auf youtube
geben weil das buch ist ja schließlich
was besonderes vielleicht irgendwann mal
in ferner zukunft aber wir lassen hier
so rezept ich erstmal in dem buch und
ich hoffe ihr freut euch über meine
rezept auswahl vor allem weil es ist
auch 29 herzhafte und süße rezepte sind
also ich wollte kein reines kochbuch
sondern ich wollte auch schöne des erst
zeigen
ich habe mir auch noch gedanken gemacht
was für blätter ich nehme oder wie die
seiten ob sie beschichtet sein sollen
oder nicht ich hab mich jetzt dafür
entschieden dass meine seiten eine
beschichtung haben und es dürfte euch
jetzt nicht so wie laminiert forschern
sondern es ist wirklich eine sehr feine
beschichtung oben drauf und wenn euch
mal während des kochens irgendwie fleck
drauf kommt einfach schnell wegwischen
nur dann sieht man da auch nichts mehr
es kleinigkeiten die wir uns gedanken
gemacht haben also hier steckt wirklich
so viel so viele gedanken stecken hier
drinnen alles mögliche überlegt was von
vorteil ist was soll hier noch unbedingt
beachtet werden
natürlich ist dann hardcover also könnt
euch das auch jan also in die küche
stellen dass wir wirklich auch freuen
und ja ich freue mich jetzt einfach wenn
die ersten das buch erhalten die
vorbestellungen sind natürlich schon
raus beziehungsweise gehen jetzt auch
noch raus den nächsten tagen und ab
sofort könnt ihr das natürlich auch zu
anderen produkt mit dazu bestellen im
shop das ist auch kein problem
und natürlich darf da haben sie in
diesem video nicht fehlen dann haben sie
hat alle fotos selber gemacht und ja ich
weiß was zählt du einfach wärst du die
zeit so erlebt habe habe ich auf die
palme gebracht
es war cool also war es auf jeden fall
denn ich gedacht dass es so stressig ist
niemals für mich war es auch was neues
weil ich zum erstmal keine
dieses gemacht hätte das hallo fotos
also wirklich für mich was einfach weil
ich musste dafür der affären dann kann
ich essen war das nicht aber für dich
ich glaube kurzfristig als ich kann sich
dass das koch alleine dann das
dekorieren noch nebenbei das ist schon
auf jeden fall nicht gerade zucker
steckt ja was schöne wahl haben sie bald
die ganze zeit bei mir und wenn ich
irgendwann mal so um 2 uhr morgens die
krise die sich keine mehr
und es ist wirklich also im durch durch
das er sich vorstellen dass ich hier die
ganze zeit und die krise gekriegt aber
soll ein anschlussprojekt worauf ich
jetzt umso stolzer bin das ist jetzt
hier liegt und haben einmal da ja was
das ist ja nicht nur deine hauptstadt
also du machst du noch was anderes du
bist doch nebenbei wie das gehalt das er
neben einer kooperation gehabt das ist
ganz normal dass es dann irgendwo zu ja
ich glaube das habe ich gar nicht
erwähnt in dem video
was denken die leute sind dann kocht zu
halten fotografiert aber wir haben da
wirklich diese mussten halt videos
drehen und shop und dann auch
kooperationen wie du sagst und das war
ja das war eigentlich nur so nach der
arbeit noch mal das projekt aber ich
würde sagen 'du weißt kommt meistert
ausschreibung wird sie die fotos zu den
punkt für mich so was neu ist und auf
jeden fall also feedback bitte unten
rein schreiben und ansonsten würde ich
jetzt gerne noch drei büchern euch
verlost gerne auch mit signierung
schreibt ihr dann euren namen am besten
mit dazu und schreibt einfach wie seid
ihr auf uns gestoßen oder haben sie eine
gute frage
wie seid ihr auf uns gestoßen schreibt
uns das und dann könnt ihr eines von
drei büchern gewinnen und an sondern
fünf bücher okay finde ich ja alles klar
fünf bücher könnt ihr gewinnen und
ansonsten werde ich euch den link zum
buch natürlich in die info box sitzt
nicht danke euch also dass hier
hingeschaut habt und wer weiß wann das
nächste buch kommt vielleicht wird das
nächste buch wie ein reines backbuch was
meint ihr schreibt mir doch mal runter
ich habe schon gedacht so das nächste
wäre vielleicht seine torten und wurde
so eine gute idee okay ihr lieben
macht's gut eure kiki und
erste helfer fertig ich bin einfach
fertig wir sind fertig wir sind einfach
wirklich montag 15 der dritte 2021
gesprungen ach so habe ich ja sagen denn
die sind fertig mit der welt wir sind
fertig mit dem mit dem kopftuch macht
zumindest für den teil
[Musik]
sterben nicht wochenlange arbeit
wochenlange schlaflose nächte
augenringe des todes ist er fertig haben
sie kann das glaub ich nicht ob das
nicht sollten leute das buch das hat
schweiß blut und tränen aber er sieht
sie zieht es mich in den büchern sagen
machen nein heißt es da war er also da
ist kein blut oder so mache ich keine
sorgen auch keine schweißflecken oder so
aber da steckt viel lieber nicht schwer
solch und ihr müsst euch auch vorstellen
das ist ein das ist ein team den gewesen
ja also haben sie umgeht ihr habt haben
euch mit rezepten rezept versorgt ja das
buch wird meister wer ja also eigentlich
ist es ja so als sage ich mal richtig
weil ja sagte ich weiß ganz natürlich
rennen erkläre ich euch das war ja macht
erzähl doch eigentlich ist es so dass
man ein buch erst mal verschickt und
dann wartet man so darauf dass die leute
was daraus nach back und nachkochen und
der goldkurs kam gut an aber ich weiß in
diesem moment wo wir das letzte bild
geschossen haben dieses buch wird der
oberknaller next level abriss
mit echter sich wollen anstatt sich also
weiß was ich auch weiter stolz macht ja
das ist natürlich gezwungen das obwohl
man trotzdem lacht
man könnte ich den westen
woher die kraftwerke werden kann kommen
sagt damit zu wir müssen beobachten
haben die liste hat auch das buch zu
schreiben kommt nichts geschrieben habe
und diese von mir noch schwarz-grün
einmal welcher sein
ich mache aber schon so viel energie
dass jetzt so schön die kirche auf
[Musik]